es geht um die ukraine hilfe es geht um
nahrungsmittelversorgung weltweit und
dafür liegen zwei anträge vor zum einen
eine aus der unionsfraktion der den
titel trägt der ukraine jetzt und in
zukunft helfen
nahrungsmittelversorgung in der welt
sicherstellen sowie europäische und
deutsche landwirtschaft krisenfest
gestalten und es liegt vor ein antrag
aus der fdp-fraktion mit dem titel im
welthunger ideologiefrei bekämpfen
stilllegungsflächen rund ökologische
vorrangflächen für nahrungs- und
futtermittel
futtermittelproduktion freigeben knapp
70 minuten sind angesetzt für die
debatte zu diesem punkt die sich wie
gesagt daneben insgesamt mit der
hungersnot unten in der welt
beschäftigen wie sie bekämpft werden
kann wie man abhilfe schaffen kann und
das ganze natürlich auch mit einem
besonderen blick auf die lage in der
ukraine nicht nur was die bevölkerung
und die ernährung der menschen in der
ukraine angeht sondern ukraine gilt ja
auch als eine der kornkammern der welt
und viel getreide von dort wird in die
welt exportiert aus der ukraine heraus
der erste redner ist steffen bilger
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unionsfraktion
der russische angriff auf die ukraine
hat entsetzliche folgen zuallererst für
die menschen in der ukraine und die
jüngsten ereignisse erfüllen uns mit
trauer und entsetzen und auch mit wut
und abscheu gegenüber denjenigen die
hierfür verantwortlich sind
die auswirkungen des kriegs spüren wir
in ganz unterschiedlichen bereichen und
einer ist die nahrungsmittelversorgung
wir sorgen uns akut um die versorgung
der menschen im kriegsgebiet wir sorgen
uns um die diesjährige ernte in der
ukraine der ukrainische
landwirtschaftsminister geht er davon
aus dass bis zur hälfte der diesjährigen
landwirtschaftlichen produktion durch
den krieg verloren geht und wir sorgen
uns auch um die ernährungslage global
das eine sind die kosten von
landwirtschaftlichen gütern insbesondere
getreide auf dem weltmarkt und das
andere ist die frage der verfügbarkeit
30 millionen tonnen getreide aus der
ukraine können zurzeit nicht geliefert
werden wegen des kriegs sagt david
beasley der chef des un
welternährungsprogramms spricht von
einer krise wie das world food program
sie noch nicht erlebt habe in
deutschland werden wir nicht hungern
müssen wir müssen uns aber einstellen
auf teils leere regale darauf dass
bestimmte produkte oder marken mitunter
nicht in den läden zu finden sein werden
oder rationiert werden so wie es heute
ja auch schon beim einkauf erleben aber
hungern das werden wir in deutschland
nicht müssen in anderen regionen der
welt kann es aber ganz schnell anders
aussehen und damit sind wir direkt bei
unserer verantwortung auch ganz konkret
in der landwirtschaftspolitik im
bundestag wie bundesrat nachher bei der
abstimmung über die frage der nutzung
von brachflächen in der bundesregierung
und auf europäischer ebene
der agrarkommissar wotschikowsky sagt
unsere reaktion sollte es sein dass wir
in der eu in diesem jahr mehr
lebensmittel produzieren der kollege
busen von der fdp hat es in der
haushaltsdebatte vor zwei wochen richtig
gesagt der druck flächen zu
bewirtschaften statt sie stillzulegen
wird mit jedem tag des krieges größer
landwirtschaftsminister backhaus von der
spd aus mecklenburg vorpommern sagt es
sei gut und mit blick auf die zu
erwartende verschärfung der
lebensmittelversorgung richtig
brachflächen zeitweise zur
bewirtschaftung freizugeben und jetzt
noch gestern dem ministerpräsidenten
konferenz die einstimmig beschlossen hat
deutschland trifft auch eine humanitäre
verpflichtung einen beitrag zur
weltweiten versorgungssicherheit mit
nahrungsmitteln zu leisten die
ministerpräsidenten fordern die
bundesregierung daher auf die
möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen um das
vorhandene potenzial der landwirtschaft
konsequent zu nutzen so der beschluss
von gestern abend fazit so ziemlich alle
haben es erkannt in der krise geht ein
augen zu und durch nicht geht kein
weiter so als wäre nichts passiert die
jetzige krise situation erfordert eine
reaktion und das sind sie gefordert
bis zu als dem er nicht aussitzen
sondern handeln ist jetzt das gebot der
stunde
fragt man nach argumenten für die
position des aussitzens dann hört man
ein gebetsmühlenartige svento für die
eine krise nicht gegen die andere
ausspielen aber das ist mir meine damen
und herren mit verlaub ein bisschen zu
schlicht um es klar zu sagen wir wollen
keine abkehr von unserer
nachhaltigkeitszielen aber manchmal
volland eben die bittere realität
vorübergehend andere prioritäten sie
sagen ja immer man sollte jetzt nicht
die alten sprechzeiten hervorholen wird
man sagen meine sprechzeit ist ziemlich
neu aber ihre scheinen den alten grünen
parteiprogramm zu entstanden und die
passen einfach nicht in diese zeit mein
dank
wenn globale hungersnöte und massive
marktverwerfungen und dann ist in
gunstlagen wie bei uns in mitteleuropa
schlichtweg nicht die zeit für eine
weitere extensivierung das wäre nichts
anderes als zynisch und auch unethisch
meine damen und herren wir nochmal till
backhaus von der spd zitieren bei der
agrarministerkonferenz vergangene woche
hat er mit blick auf die grünen
landwirtschaftsminister im bund und in
den ländern gesagt in meiner wahrnehmung
zitiere wurde beschwichtigt und
beschädigt ohne die realitäten
anzuerkennen und die entsprechenden
schlüsse daraus zu ziehen das spricht
doch wirklich bände was ist jetzt zu tun
konkret in deutschland muss jetzt auf
brachliegenden flächen der anbau auch
von nahrungsmitteln möglich sein und die
20 23 geplante pflicht zur stilllegung
von vier prozent der ackerflächen muss
aufgehoben werden
wir können uns ein weiteres grünes
zaudern und zögern nicht erlauben
umdenken ist jetzt das gebot der stunde
das gilt im übrigen auch für die
deutsche verhandlungsführung in brüssel
beim green deal hier braucht die
bundesregierung dringend ein update und
hier brauchen die verhandelnden
grünen-minister habeck lemke und setzte
mir dringend den klaren arbeitsauftrag
jetzt ist nicht die zeit für weitere
belastung weder für die landwirtschaft
noch für die verbraucher jetzt gehört
die ernährungssicherung in den
mittelpunkt
steffen bilger war das stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unions-fraktion er war
der erste redner in einer debatte in der
es um die nahrungsmittelversorgung in
der welt geht aber speziell auch in der
ukraine beziehungsweise auch darum was
aus der ukraine an nahrungsmittel
insbesondere in getreide exportiert wird
nächste rednerin ist natalie public aus
der spd fraktion
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen seit über sechs
wochen herrscht krieg in der ukraine
völkerrecht kriegsrecht und
menschlichkeit werden gebrochen die
menschen erleben unbeschreibliches leid
die schrecklichen bilder aus butter
lassen das ausmaß der grausamkeiten
dieses krieges nur an
doch der krieg hat nicht nur dramatische
folgen für die ukraine russland oder
europa sondern für die ganze
weltgemeinschaft den putin schafft nicht
nur unendliches leid in der ukraine
sondern auch hunger in der welt
die ukraine und aus russland sind
wichtige produzenten und exporteure für
lebensmittel allein im letzten jahr
wurden knapp
70 millionen tonnen an getreide aus der
ukraine exportiert das
welternährungsprogramm bezieht etwa 30
prozent des getreides aus der ukraine
der wegfall der ukraine als
nahrungsmittel produzentin bedeutet dass
viele länder ihren bedarf an getreide
nicht mehr decken können und millionen
menschen die hungersnot
betroffen sind vor allem länder des
globalen südens die auf das
welternährungsprogramm und auf getreide
importe angewiesen sind es sind länder
wieder jemand nigeria um bangladesch die
sowieso schon zu den ärmsten der armen
gehören
es ist unsere humanitäre verpflichtung
einen beitrag zu leisten und für die
nahrungsmittelsicherheit in der welt zu
sorgen
wir benötigen schnelle internationale
lösungen um eine weltweite hungerkrise
zu verhindern dazu gehört das natürlich
auch dass wir die lebensmittelproduktion
in europa steigern und alles dafür tun
um die märkte offen zu halten
als konsequenz hat die cdu csu fraktion
aber auch gefördert den zwölf euro
mindestlohn in für die landwirtschaft
auszusetzen genauso wie die 70 tage
regelung für die saison beschäftigten
auszuweiten wenn ihnen nichts mehr
einfällt dann kommen sie mit lohndumping
ich weiß dass einige von ihnen sich
nicht einfügen können dass es menschen
gibt die gerade am ende des monats sich
entscheiden müssen ob sie ihr auto
volltanken oder ob sie lebensmittel
einkaufen gehen nicht wenige davon
arbeiten in der landwirtschaft diese
menschen brauchen gerade jetzt eine
solidargemeinschaft die ihnen zur seite
steht die erhöhung des mindestlohns ist
eine frage von respekt und
auch wenn sie selbst in ihrer letzten
antrags fassung die forderung nach der
verschiebung der erhöhung des
mindestlohns wieder rausgenommen haben
bleibt es dabei dass sie diese krise
dafür nutzen wollen um sozialpolitische
und ökologische rückschritte zu
erreichen das werden wir mit der
sozialdemokratie so nicht mittragen
die krise darf nicht auf dem rücken
derer ausgetragen werden die hart
arbeiten aber wenig haben vor allem ist
der vorschlag aber auch realitätsfern
denn wenn die arbeit wenn wir die
arbeits und lohnbedingungen in der
landwirtschaft nicht verbessern wird es
am ende keine arbeitskräfte mehr geben
die diese arbeit verrichten in zeiten
des fachkräftemangels werden andere
sektoren die fachkräfte abwerben
lohndumping vertreibt arbeitskräfte
der krieg in der ukraine die steigenden
preise für energie und dünger aber auch
benzin belasten die landwirtschaft enorm
natürlich wird sich der mindestlohn auch
für die landwirtinnen und landwirte
finanziell merkbar machen für die
unterstützung landwirtschaftlicher
betriebe haben wir aber auch einige
instrumente in unserem koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten die wichtig sind so wollen
wir zum beispiel die unter untergrenzen
einführen dass der verkaufspreis eben
nicht unter die kosten der produktion
und der arbeitskraft fällt auch wollen
wir eine herkunftskennzeichnung um die
regionale landwirtschaft zu stärken
knochenjobs auf dem acker für löhne von
denen man nicht leben kann hingegen sind
keine antwort auf die krise das ist
ausbeutung meine damen und
wir wollen faire preise für hochwertige
produkte aber auch diejenigen die diese
produkte produkte produzieren müssen
sich diese leisten können das gehört zum
anstand dazu ihr antrag ist nicht
weitgehend genug sie spalten unsere
gesellschaft und deswegen wir werden wir
diesen abnehmen
natalie patrick war das aus der
spd-fraktion sie ist mitglied im
ausschuss für ernährung und
landwirtschaft und überhaupt nicht
einverstanden mit den hier vorliegenden
anträgen was nicht weiter überraschend
ist weil sie ja aus der unionsfraktion
und der
die kommen und gehen sofern aus der
opposition in diesem fall mit der ferse
ist der redner nächster redner afd
fraktion mitglied im ausschuss für
ernährung und landwirtschaft und wie
gesagt die afd hat auch einen eigenen
antrag in dieser debatte ich bin diese
debatte eingebracht wir begrüßen es dass
wir heute wieder über diese wichtigen
themen sprechen können hilfe für die
ukraine hilfe für die dortigen landwirte
aber auch natürlich über
lebensmittelsicherheit
selbstversorgungsgrad hier in
deutschland
ich frage mich nur wer die kollegen von
der cdu csu ich frage mich nur warum
verweigern sie sich eigentlich im
ausschuss immer dieser themen genau das
was sie heute fordern haben wir in
teilen auch in anträgen vorgelegt bitte
finden sie sich doch mal ein in die
oppositionsrolle und stärken sie die
opposition in diesem hause
ja sie haben es doch vorgestern im
ausschuss oder mittwoch mitbekommen da
hatten wir gefragt die staatssekretärin
wo wir in dieser schweren zeit in
kriegszeiten ob wir da die priory
priorisierungen etwas ändern können
klimaziele 23 jahre nach hinten schieben
und endlich den hunger zu bekämpfen
und sie wissen sie wissen wird total wie
eiskalt die antwort war ideologie vor
hungersnot ideologie vor dem schutz
unserer landwirte und da hätten dass sie
gebraucht da hätten sie opposition sein
müssen die kollegen
sie haben viele punkte richtig heute in
ihrem antrag drin das unterstützen wir
auch und wir haben es ja ähnlich
beantragt aber bitte bleiben sie bei der
lagebeurteilung und bei der
ursachenanalyse
fair und bleiben sie der bitte korrekt
warum haben denn unsere landwirte diese
herausforderungen sie waren es doch die
die immensen preissteigerungen bei den
rohstoffen und düngemitteln mit zu
verantworten haben die inflation ist auf
einem rekordhoch seit 40 jahren hoch war
sie aber schon vor dem ukraine kliniken
sie waren ist doch die den euro durch
die eu rettungspolitik verbessert haben
die energiepreise schnell in die höhe
sie haben doch die verkorkste
energiewende mit zu verantworten und das
lassen wir ihnen nicht durchgehen liebe
kolleginnen
muss ich ihnen jetzt wirklich vorrechnen
was 16 jahre merkel-regierung für die
deutsche landwirtschaft gebracht hat
es waren nicht 10.000 es waren nicht
wird 50.000 es sieht
140000 bäuerliche betriebe die
aufgegeben haben die aufgeben mussten
weil sie nicht weiter arbeiten konnten
und das lassen wir nicht durchgehen
diese agrarpolitik haben sie zu
verantworten
schauen wir mal konkret in den antrag
rein was bitteschön wollen sie denn mit
inflations beratungsstellen das ist doch
absurd wollen sie den landwirten
erklären dass sie bei 7 prozent
inflation bei zwölf prozent inflation
oder bei 15 prozent inflation machen
sollen eine spürbare entlastung unserer
landwirte das ist jetzt das gebot der
stunde liebe kollegen
es geht jetzt darum die
lebensmittelpreise für unsere
bevölkerung stabil zu halten
seit montag spüren wir in den
supermärkten in den discountern die
angezogenen preise und das sind die
erzeugerpreise noch gar nicht abgebildet
dass es noch gar nicht berücksichtigt
das ist erst der anfang der
preissteigerung die darauf noch auf uns
zukommen wird die lebensmittel müssen
doch für unsere bürger bezahlbar bleiben
liebe kollegen von der cdu csu kommen
sie erst einmal an in der opposition
dann werden sie ihren anträgen
vielleicht in zukunft zustimmen ich
danke ihnen
peter felser aus der fdp fraktion in
einer debatte des bundestages über die
nahrungsmittelversorgung weltweit aber
auch und besonders in der ukraine und in
dieser debatte redet jetzt renate künast
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
da ist eine sprecherin genau für diesen
themenbereich nämlich ernährung und
landwirtschaft
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin ich kriege
nicht unter
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
der chef des world food programms david
base lee hat gesagt der krieg der
ukraine führt zu einer katastrophe und
top zu einer bestehenden katastrophe
warum weil das wort flugprogramm schon
vor dem krieg 125 millionen menschen
ernähren muss 125 millionen menschen und
durch die verteuerung von lebensmitteln
war es da schon klar dass sie monatlich
71 millionen dollar mehr an ausgaben
schultern mussten deshalb hatten wir ja
die hinweise zb im jemen auf gekürzte
lebensmittelrationen und ich finde es
wirklich mag aber das hier zu tun als
würden die probleme des welthungers
gerade mit dem krieg auf die ukraine
erst entstehen nein sie haben sich
wirklich sehen wollen meine damen und
herren
sie beziehen sich auf die ukraine
die exportiert etwa 70 millionen tonnen
getreide jedes jahr weizen mais andere
sorten fast ein drittel der globalen
weizenexporte stammte schon vor dem
krieg aus russland und der ukraine viele
länder der nahe osten afrika waren
angewiesen und gleichzeitig immer das
makabre zu sagen hat kenia jetzt glaube
dritte ja dann auch
gleichzeitig hat kenia tausende tonnen
blumen nach europa exportiert darin
sehen sie das in unserer ernährungslage
etwas schief liegt damit müssen wir uns
beschäftigen mehr sagen jetzt kommen sie
mit einem antrag
der sagt zum beispiel internationaler
organisationen stärken so weit so gut
dann sagen sie den kredit war hierbei
ein redner aus hof und die gab also wie
gemeinsame agrarpolitik der eu
vorurteilsfrei bewerten und schon ich
habe jetzt gedacht nun kommt die
vorurteilsfreie bewertung aber schon
kommt die übliche ideologische
bewertungen brachflächen aussetzen
pestizideinsatz ausweiten die die
agrarpolitik reform um ein jahr
verschieben meine damen und herren das
kenne ich seit mindestens 20 jahren
daran ist nichts neues also mindestens
20 jahre alter bilder gehe ich mal auf
die braten 1 4 prozent der agrarflächen
sind brachen
stillgelegte flächen die die erträge am
ende aber kaum geschmälert haben warum
weil das grants ertrag standorte sind im
wesentlichen so sagt man das in der
fachsprache da sind gewässerrandstreifen
andere landschaftselemente wo ich sage
danke an cem özdemir und das ministerium
dass sie an dieser stelle stand halten
und dazu eines machen dass man den
aufwuchs nutzen kann als futtermittel
das ist die effektivste art etwas zu
nutzen weil wenn sie umgekehrt was
machen was die cdu will die sind dinge
die schwer zu bearbeiten sind dann haben
noch mit pestiziden versehen meine damen
und herren dann ist der ertrag geringer
als die ökologische belastung das können
sie nicht ernsthaft wollen
ja geringe erträge schwer zu
bewirtschaften das gilt für diese fächer
und selbst wenn wir die stilllegung
aufheben würden meine damen und herren
während das eine erhöhung der eu
getreidemenge um 4,4 prozent auf die
weltweite produktion weil sie wollen ja
mit dieser geschichte die welt ernähren
auf die weltweite produktion werden dass
0,8 mit 0,4 prozent wollen sie die welt
retten meine damen und herren das
beleidigt unserem internet und sie
wollen mit den schlechtesten ab
standorten und den geringsten erträgen
bei uns die die bauern gerne
stilllegen dafür noch geld kriege meine
damen und herren mit diesen 0,4 prozent
wollen sie nicht nur die welt retten
sondern die wunderbaren böden der
ukraine ersetzen das glaubt kein mensch
und dann kommen sie noch pestizide auf
diesen fast ertraglosen standorten
einsetzen sie haben aber noch zeitgleich
gesagt dass die bauern belastet sind
weil die pestiziden preise steigen wenn
sie dass da auch noch einsätzen auf 4
prozent der vielleicht steigen die
pestizid preise noch weiter was wollen
sie eigentlich
so in deutschland werden die
stilllegungsflächen zurzeit 350.000
hektar
350.000 hektar allein die anbaufläche
für winterweizen in der ukraine waren
6,4 millionen
645 millionen hektar sie wollen also mit
350.000 6 und 6 4 5 millionen hektar
ersetzen und dann noch die welt ernähren
meine damen und herren wenn sie wirklich
ernsthaft fast wollen dann reden sie mal
über die hard facts wenn wir zum
beispiel 30 prozent der schweinehaltung
reduzieren dann würden würden wir eine
million hektar fläche einsparen meine
damen und herren das wären beitrag zur
welternährung und zwar egal ob die
fläche bei unserer woanders anfällt dann
könnte man damit menschen ernähren
folgen sie doch bitte und besser 600
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern die drei hebel
vorschlagen nämlich dass wir die
kurzfristigen shops bewältigen dass wir
uns konzentrieren auf die menschliche
gesundheit entlang frist die nachhaltige
entwicklung gewährleisten sehen sie
der hebel 1 ist
zwei punkten zwei drittel der
ackerfläche in deutschland nutzen wir
für futtermittel wenn wir das reduzieren
haben wir eben fünf millionen tonnen
getreide dazu sagen sie kein wort meine
damen und herren hebe zwei mehr
hülsenfrüchte weitere ökologisierung das
würde heißen die fanta ford strategie
der eu die ja den stickstoff überschuss
halbieren will den ökolandbau ausweiten
will unterstützen wie cem özdemir es tut
kein wort von ihnen dazu das wollen sie
lieber nach hinten schieben und ehrlich
gesagt glaubt ihm kein mensch dass es
nur ein jahr nach hinten schieben wollen
und dann der hebel 3
lebensmittelverschwendung auch kein wort
von ihnen dazu meine damen und herren
ich sage ihnen eins die grundlage der
landwirtschaft unserer ernährung sind
gesunde böden ausreichend wasser
stabiles klima eine reichhaltige
artenvielfalt und deutschland hat allein
in den letzten 20 jahren so viel wasser
verloren wie der boden wasser hat dazu
sagen sie auch nicht sie wollen nur
reformen die die landwirtschaft
unterstützen nach hinten schieben sie
wollen allenfalls kleine und kosmetische
wirklich kleine kosmetische
operationen die am ende aber nicht
helfen um ein letzter satz meine damen
und herren es gibt auf dieser welt genug
nahrungsmittel potenziell sie sind aber
falsch verteilt sie warten falsch
genutzt meine damen und herren wir
wollen die reform weitermachen um
wirklich dieses jahr und in zukunft
menschen zu ernähren und deshalb bin ich
froh dass der erste mehr haltung zeit
oder an der stelle zwar bei der
fütterung hilft aber nicht kaputt macht
was uns erhält danke
renate künast sprecherin für und der
landwirtschaft der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen hält den antrag der
unionsfraktion zur
nahrungsmittelversorgung für nicht
effizient bzw gewinnbringend die
maßnahmen gegen vorgeschlagen sind hören
wir was in altendorf dazu sagt sie ist
in der linksfraktion sprecherin für
landwirtschaft ländliche räume und
tierschutz präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte kolleginnen von
der fraktion von der unionsfraktion wenn
sie wir fordern nahrungsmittelversorgung
sicherstellen landwirtschaft krisenfest
gestalten wissen sie auch dass es die
probleme schon viel länger gibt und die
ursachen tiefer liegen die defizite sind
durch den krieg in der ukraine
wie durch ein brennglas sichtbar
geworden und ja sie wurden auch
verschärft aber
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
wir haben es eben gerade aufgehört haben
vor wenigen tagen fachübergreifend in
einem offenen brief festgestellt die
weltweite nahrungssicherheit wird nicht
durch die einschränkung des
nahrungsmittels angebotes verursacht
sondern durch eine ungleiche verteilung
das ist fakt und das wissen sie
jahrzehntelang haben sie die möglichkeit
zur veränderung verschlafen davon wollen
sie jetzt nichts wissen unsere forderung
nach einer sozial gerechten und
ökologischen landwirtschaft national und
international haben sie immer abgelehnt
dieser antrag der union ist ein
rundumschlag mit dem ganz viel auf
einmal angepackt werden soll ja und es
gibt auch gute ansätze bei der forderung
zum beispiel nach einem sonderprogramm
zur abfederung der gravierendsten folgen
steigender nahrungsmittelpreise oder ihr
ruf nach einer internationalen
preiskontrolle aber ich bezweifle ob sie
das auch wirklich wollen vor allem wenn
man bedenkt dass auch mit ihnen quasi in
einer ganz großen koalition
das 100 milliarden rüstungs cup im raum
steht dadurch werden mittel für den
sozial ökologischen umbau der
gesellschaft und auch der agrarpolitik
auf jahre fiel ja auch wir wollen die
entwicklungshilfe aufstocken ich habe es
gerade in der letzten sitzungswoche an
dieser stelle massiv kritisiert dass die
entwicklungshilfegelder im haushalt
gekürzt wurden es muss mehr und nicht
weniger geld für eine echte
entwicklungsarbeit in den ländern
eingesetzt werden aber solange wir durch
dumpingpreise und exportgüter den
heimischen bauern die erwerbs- und
lebensgrundlage zerstören haben wir
nichts gelernt
entwicklungshilfe muss dazu beitragen
sind windmarkt wieder aufzubauen für
dinge die in den ländern auch selbst
produziert werden können und auch hier
gilt regionale wirtschaftskreisläufe
sind zu stärken anstatt die profitgier
von konzernen zu bedienen national und
international
wir brauchen in den entwicklungsländern
und auch hierzulande endlich eine
rückbesinnung auf die eigene
ernährungssouveränität zum beispiel
durch den aufbau von regionalen
wirtschaftskreisläufen die verhandlungen
auf augenhöhe zwischen produzenten und
abnehmer die kostendeckende produktion
bezahlbaren bogen und die ausreichende
honorierung von agrarumweltmaßnahmen
hierdurch würden die kleineren und
mittleren unternehmen gestärkt
heute der größte teil des gewinns bei
der vermarktung hängen das wissen wir
der reibach wird in der mitte mehr
gemacht bei handelsketten und konzern
auf der strecke bleiben am ende die
produzenten und am anderen ende die
konsumenten ändern sie das mit uns
und liebe unionsfraktion von einer
begrenzung der marktmacht im handel ist
bei ihnen nicht die rede sie setzten
sogar noch einen drauf die ohnehin zu
kritisierende 70 tage regelung für
saison arbeiter- und saison
arbeiterinnen als kurzfristige
beschäftigte ohne soziale absicherung
wollen sie auf 115 tage ausweiten das
ist der falsche reflex wir sehen den
schraubstock in dem sich die landwirte
befinden als erzeuger aber der druck
darf nicht nach unten weitergegeben
werden an die beschäftigten das ist der
falsche weg wir fordern eine faire
bezahlung und vor allem vollen sozialen
schutz
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren um
die nationalen europäische
landwirtschaft krisenfest zu machen
bedeutet dass es wesentlich mehr als das
herumdoktern an symptomen
und das blinde vertrauen in die nicht
vorhandenen sogenannten
selbstheilungskräfte des marktes das
system gehört vom kopf auf die füße
gestellt vielen dank
in latendorf aus der fraktion die linke
sprecherin für landwirtschaft ländliche
räume und tierschutz und um mal einen
ganz bestimmten aspekt heraus zugreifen
welche durchaus seine rolle spielt
nämlich exporte aus der ukraine eben
beispielsweise
pflanzenöl oder weizen aber auch ne
metalle da stehen in der ukraine im
moment fast
24.000 waggons mit exportgütern und
warten darauf die ukrainische west
grenze zu überqueren also auch
waren die hier im westen erwartet werden
und gleichzeitig kommt die meldung der
deutschen presseagentur von vor wenigen
minuten dass bei einem raketenangriff
auf dem bahnhof der ostukrainischen
stadt krems nach offiziellen angaben den
dutzende menschen getötet und verletzt
worden sind also auf der einen seite das
drama um tote und verletzte auf der
anderen seite aber auch weitere
schwierigkeiten was den transport von
gütern angeht in der ukraine
das ist glaube ich auch oder sind auch
ein zwei punkte die man im zusammenhang
mit lisa debatte nicht aus den augen
verlieren sollte wir schauen auf den
nächsten redner gero clemens hocker ist
das aus der fdp-fraktion und dort
landwirtschaftspolitische sprecher
mit jedem tag den der krieg in der
ukraine andauert steigt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass menschen in
anderen ländern in den anderen regionen
dieser welt tatsächlich hunger werden
und natürlich haben sie liebe frau
kollegin künast recht dass wir das
alleine nicht verhindert werden können
aber wir können einen beitrag leisten
dafür ich glaube sogar dass wir die
moralische verpflichtungen haben einen
beitrag zu leisten dafür dass die
preissteigerung in deutschland auch dass
die nöte in ärmeren regionen dieser welt
moderater ausfallen und ich glaube dass
wir wenn wir das nicht tun und sind eine
eine moralische sackgasse hinein begeben
aus der wir nur ganz schwer wieder
herauskommt werden wir haben ja
ich weiß übrigens wie schwierig das ist
wenn man
kurzfristige externe ereignisse
sozusagen die eigene meinungsbildung mit
integrieren muss ich sags ganz
unumwunden ich habe als abgeordneter
sächsischen landtages gestritten für die
kernenergie als brückentechnologie als
co2 neutraler technologie hin zu
erneuerbaren energien und dann passierte
fukushima und quasi über nacht wurden
dann an anderer stelle entscheidung
getroffen und man musste auch seine
eigenen positionen überdenken und am
ende auch revidieren und ich habe das
gemacht um eine partei das gemacht und
ich glaube dass es situationen gibt
meine damen und herren die so mächtig
sind dass man quasi als ewiggestriger
dastehen würde wenn man eben nicht
einlenkt und wenn man nicht seine eigene
haltung seiner eigenen förderung im
lichte der aktuellen entwicklungen noch
mal auf den prüfstand stellt das war für
mich fukushima und die energiewende
seiner zeit und ich hoffe dass der eine
oder andere hier in diesem haus seiner
haltung aufgrund der jüngsten
entwicklungen des krieges in der ukraine
noch einmal überdenken kollegen
und an die union gewandt auch wenn der
vorliegende antrag einige punkte richtig
benannt werden wir ihm aus vor allem im
grunde nicht zustimmen können es
suggeriert nämlich dass die menschen in
diesem land und auch diese
bundesregierung in den vergangenen
wochen und monaten quasi tatenlos
gewesen während bei der bewältigung der
flüchtlingskrise und da will ich ihnen
ganz ausdrücklich sagen herr kollege
thies das ist ein schlag ins gesicht all
derjenigen menschen in diesem lande die
gegenwärtig zusammenrücken um platz zu
machen für flüchtlinge die nach
deutschland kommen die auch keine angst
haben vor steigenden nebenkosten das ist
ein schlag ins gesicht all der
unternehmen die spenden und auch hier
viele kolleginnen und kollegen
ansprechen und sich erkundigen wie kann
die logistik bewältigt werden das ist
ein schlag ins gesicht all derer männer
und frauen die in den ausnahme behörden
arbeiten und tag und nacht dafür
streiten und arbeiten dass die menschen
aus der ukraine hier eine
menschenwürdige unterbringung bekommen
und das ist auch ein schlag ins gesicht
der des krisenstabs der bundesregierung
die einen hervorragenden job macht bei
der bewältigung der logistischen
herausforderung bei der bewältigung der
flüchtlingssituation verehrte
kolleginnen kollegen die union
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen diese
bundesregierung hat den anspruch nach
jahrzehnten ökonomie und ökologie
miteinander zu vereinen und ich sage
ihnen mir fällt kein wirtschaftsbereich
ein wo das schon jetzt im jahre 2022
besser gelungen wären und es ist richtig
diesen weg fort zu beschreiben aber
dieser ich sage mal konstruierte
konflikt den sie mit ihrem antrag auf
machen dass sozusagen bewirtschaftung
von flächen im gegensatz zur ökologie
stünde das ist eine auffassung aus den
1970 er jahren wir haben die technologie
beides miteinander zu vereinen gerade
bei unseren landwirten ist doch
tatsächlich so dass wir das know how
haben dass diejenigen flächen die gerade
landwirtschaftlich genutzt wird häufig
noch eine höhere ökologische bedeutung
haben als diejenigen flächen die einfach
brachliegen und deswegen verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen ist ihr antrag
komplett aus der zeit gefallen und wird
nicht unsere zustimmung für den vielen
dank mit gesagt gero clemens hocker aus
der fdp-fraktion wo er land
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher ist an
die adresse der unions fraktion die
einen der beiden anträge die hier gerade
diskutiert werden vorgelegt hat der der
ukraine jetzt und in zukunft helfen will
aber auch die nahrungsmittelversorgung
in der welt sicherstellen sowie
europäische und deutsche landwirtschaft
krisenfest gestalten und dazu jetzt aus
der unions fraktion hans jürgen thies
ich glaube sie haben in ihrer rede schon
selbst die antwort darauf gegeben
weshalb wir als union auch in sachfragen
mit ihnen von der afg nicht
zusammenarbeiten können und werden das
nur in replik zu ihnen und frau kollegin
künast ich muss sagen ich bin nicht nur
irritiert ich bin ein stück weit auch
betroffen von ihren ausführungen ja das
muss ich ganz deutlich sagen wenn sie
auf der einen seite sagen ja das
hungerproblem ist nicht neu auf dieser
welt handeln völlig recht aber es ist
hunger problem wird noch massiver stärkt
durch die jetzige ukraine krise und wenn
sie dann sagen die freigabe von
ökologischen vorrangflächen würde doch
nur im einstelligen prozentbereich oder
sogar 0,1 prozent bereich nur die
produktion erhöhen und steigern aber
wenn es uns auf diese art und weise
gelingt auch nur eine million menschen
weltweit fort wo es nur zusätzlich zu
bewahren dann ist das ein wert an sich
und einen erfolg und es ist zynisch wenn
die das hofcafé da in frage stellen was
muss ich nur ich sage ja
kommen sie wieder etwas butter neuer
zeiten erfordern neue entscheidungen und
bitte verstehen sie mich nicht falsch
wir haben im letzten jahr die gap aus
voller überzeugung
mit geschlossen und wir wollen an den
ökologischen umbau wir wollen an den
agrar und klimapolitischen zielen auch
grundsätzlich festhalten das will ich
hier an dieser stelle deutlich sagen um
dieses in frage stellen die union war er
verhaftet in den in den entscheidungen
der siebzigerjahre mal klarzustellen
eingestehen zu diesem ziel nur wir
müssen doch in der gegenwärtigen
krisensituation die prioritäten anders
setzen das schreibt mir das
entscheidende zu sein und deswegen geht
es jetzt jetzt geht es darum uhr zu
stellen mehr produktion mehr getreide zu
produzieren um auch ausgleichend auf
dieser rasant steigenden
getreidepreise zu reagieren durch den
krieg in der ukraine
ist auch für die heimische
landwirtschaft eine völlig neue
gefechtslage entstanden wir brauchen
jetzt kurzfristige lösungen die
eu-kommission hat dazu auch uns
vorgemacht wie die gap richtlinien
gelockert werden können aber herr
bundesminister zu mir gefällt nicht viel
mehr ein als die zusätzliche beweidung
von vorrangflächen das halten wir
deutlich viel zu wenig wir hatten auch
gehofft als union sie würden maßnahmen
die schon angeschoben worden sind aber
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ihre doch
sehr seichten ausführungen in der
letzten haushaltsdebatte vor 14 tagen
die haben uns sehr enttäuscht das waren
kurzfristige
ankündigungen die notwendige hilfen soll
brauchen weg gebracht werden bisher
haben wir davon noch nichts gesehen sie
haben also programme erwähnt aber wo
sind diese programme wo werden sie
umgesetzt also es geht darum jetzt
wirklich die ernährungssicherheit in
unserem lande aber auch weltweit zu
sichern eile geboten hungerbekämpfung
muss aktuell vorrang haben vor
klimaschutz ich jahre aktuell und tempo
wer so was können wir kurzfristig tun
wir brauchen einen ernährungs gipfel mit
allen denkbaren akteuren angesiedelt im
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium als
zuständigem fachwissen und da darf nicht
nur schöngeredet werden da muss auch
gehandelt werden und zunächst brauchen
wir eine bestandsaufnahme
wir brauchen eine bestandsaufnahme bei
welchen nahrungsmitteln gibt es
versorgungsengpässe
wie sieht es um die lieferketten aus was
es mit preissteigerungen und zwar nicht
nur bei getreide bei lebensmittel
sondern auch zb war den energiekosten
und das ganze muss doch auch noch unter
dem sozial ökonomischen aspekt
betrachtet werden denn das kommt mir in
der diskussion bisweilen etwas zu kurz
wir müssen auch schauen ob wir dich die
agrarreform
mindestens um ein jahr verschieben wir
können jetzt an flächen und stilllegungs
programm wie zu friedenszeiten
festhalten wir brauchen jetzt nicht
weniger wir brauchen jetzt mehr an
produktionen das gilt sowohl für
futtermittel als auch für
lebensmittelproduktion unser antrag
enthält dringlicher agrarpolitische
handelspolitische und auch
entwicklungspolitische forderungen an
die bundesregierung um die
ernährungssicherheit zu gewährleisten
herr bundesminister ad sie mir bitte
heben sie sich positiv von dem handlungs
schwachen
kabinettskollegin feser und lambrecht ab
werden sie jetzt aktiv zügig und
ergebnisorientiert vielen herzlichen
dank
hans-jürgen teams aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion der bundestag
diskutiert über zwei anträge zum thema
welternährung
nahrungsmittelversorgung in der welt
aber auch um den umgang mit stilllegungs
und ökologischen vorrangflächen einem
antrag aus der fdp-fraktion der nächste
redner aus der spd-fraktion manuell gaza
etwas größer
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen acht jahre bleiben uns noch bis
20.30 soll es auf der welt keinen hunger
mehr geben das ist das zweite der 17
weltweit nachhaltigkeitsziele auf die
sich fast alle staaten der welt
verständigt haben selbst vor dem
einsetzen der weltweiten corona pandemie
überliefern überaus ambitioniertes ziel
der brutale angriffskrieg von putin auf
die ukraine rückt dieses ziel nicht nur
in weiter ferne jetzt riskiert auch
alles was wir bislang erreicht haben die
ukraine und russland sind die
kornkammern für einen großteil der welt
und das gilt insbesondere für den
globalen süden auf russland und die
ukraine entfallen etwa zwölf prozent
aller weltweit gehandelten kilokalorien
pro panzer rollen können keine traktoren
fahren wo gekämpft wird kann nicht gesät
und geerntet werden diese unterbrechung
der globalen versorgungskette trifft
import abhängige länder des globalen
südens wie somalia den libanon jemen
unmittelbar und besonders hatte die
preissteigerung auf den weltmärkten
betonen in erster linie die
ernährungssicherheit der ärmsten der
armen im koalitionsvertrag haben wir uns
das ziel gesetzt hunger zu bekämpfen und
weltweite ernährungssicherheit zu
erreichen auch dieses ziel und vor allem
für seine erreichung notwendigen mittel
müssen im lichte der aktuellen
geschehnisse neu bewertet werden denn
ernährung ist ein existenzielles
menschenrecht das nicht profitinteressen
überlassen werden darf
gerade laufen die haushaltsberatung zur
förderung von ernährungsprogramm im
globalen süden der bundeskanzlerin sowie
ministerin svenja schulze haben bereits
zugesichert dass zusätzliche gelder zur
verfügung gestellt werden und das ist
aufgrund der humanitären notlage auch
genau richtig so die angekündigten 430
millionen sind eine wichtige antwort auf
die akute not mit der wir uns im moment
konfrontiert sind ein entscheidender
faktor für die langfristige weltweite
ernährungssicherheit ist der klimawandel
eben völlig richtig angesprochen wo
klima schocks und extremwetter
ereignisse bieten ist der hunger nie
weit die produktivität von kleinen
bäuerlichen familienbetrieben die 80
prozent übrigens der globalen produktion
ausmachen hängt direkt von
umweltbedingungen wie dem klima der
wasserverfügbarkeit und der
fruchtbarkeit von würden ab
und mit etwas verwunderung musste ich
feststellen dass sie mit dem
bürokratischen hemmnissen bei der
neuordnung der welt warenströme
eigentlich die einhaltung von
menschenrechts- und umwelt standards
machen und ich versichere ihnen an
dieser stelle dass die wahrung von
menschenrechten nicht der grund für die
aktuellen herausforderungen entlang der
globalen lieferketten sind stattdessen
werden die in neuen eu
rechtsvorschriften den ökologischen
wandel voran bringen für unternehmen
rechtssicherheit schaffen und für mehr
transparenz bei verbrauchern sorgen und
das ist auch gut so
neben dem ausschuss für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit bin ich so genau so wie
meine vorrednerin natalie public auch im
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales unter
vierten saison arbeiterinnen und
erntehelferin verrichten harte
körperliche arbeit unter sehr
schwierigen bedingungen und häufig zu
niedrigen löhnen dieser zustand riskiert
nicht nur die sicherung ausreichender
arbeitskraft im landwirtschaftssektor
sondern führt alle argumente zugunsten
der weltweiten ernährungssicherung ad
absurdum sozial sanders senden um den
hunger zu bekämpfen das ist eine mehr
als fragwürdige strategie
das problem der zu niedrigen
erzeugerpreise für agrar produkte und
der mangel an beschäftigten in der
landwirtschaft darf und kann nicht
gelöst werden indem man sozialstandards
sind
anstatt sozial und umweltstandards
preiszugeben brauchen wir jetzt
kraftvolle maßen haben sowie die bereits
infizierten nothalt nothilfe
finanzierungen und langfristige lösung
für die strukturellen probleme in der
landwirtschaft und sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen der cdu csu
fraktion in ihrem antrag stehen durchaus
sinnvolle dinge gerade im bereich der
finanzierung da kann man denke ich in
einem bereich mit gehen wovon allerdings
auch die bundesregierung schon einiges
bearbeitet einiges auf den weg gebracht
wurde lassen sie uns in dieser
schwierigen situation konstruktiv
zusammenarbeiten auch alle 22 punkte
konnte in diesen fünf minuten jetzt
nicht eingehen aber ich hoffe ich habe
einige geschafft und meinen dank das ist
mir an dieser stelle noch einmal
besonders wichtig geht an die ukrainerin
und ukraine an alle dort aber in dieser
debatte ganz besonders an die menschen
in der landwirtschaft arbeiten in der
logistik die unter katastrophalen
schwierigen umständen gerade einen
wahnsinnigen job machen und alles
rausholen was geht und ich bin ihnen
sehr dankbar und meine fraktion und die
regierungsfraktion ich glaube das ganze
haus sei jetzt ein ganz großes zeichen
der solidarität in die ukraine 40
manuel kabinett noch mal an die menschen
in der ukraine und ihre
mehr als schwierige lage in diesen
wochen während der bundestag über
ukraine hilfen redet über
nahrungsmittelversorgung eben auch mit
der nahrungsmittel für über die
nahrungsmittelversorgung in der ukraine
ist liegen zwei anträge vor unter
anderem eine aus der afg fraktion und
hierzu setzte bernd schattner eben aus
der reiff die fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die extensivierung der landwirtschaft in
den vergangenen drei jahrzehnten hat zu
einem dramatischen rückgang der
tierhaltung und der damit verbundenen
eigenversorgung des landes mit
nahrungsmitteln geführt lebensmittel
wurden als ramschware angesehen unsere
heimischen landwirte als angebliche
große co2 verursache abgestempelt und
damit zum feindbild der gesellschaft in
deutschland deklariert schon vor der
ukraine krise sind enorme anstieg der
erzeugerpreise für milch fleisch und
getreide zu verzeichnen gewesen davon
profitiert haben aber in keinster weise
unsere landwirte da die
produktionskosten noch deutlich stärker
gewachsen sind aber was sind denn die
gründe für diese preisexplosion bei
nahrungsmitteln kraftstoffen und
mineraldünger es ist genau ihre links
grüne politik die mit sätzen wie weniger
fleisch zu essen wäre ein beitrag gegen
putin oder wir brauchen jetzt ein
temporäres tempolimit auf unseren
autobahnen um so schnell es geht
unabhängig von russischem öl zu werden
die grammatik dieses satzes stammt
übrigens von der bundesvorsitzenden der
partei der grünen frau lang selbst diese
beiden sätze zeigen exemplarisch auch
der bundesregierung fehlt ja nötige
sachverstand um die aktuellen probleme
zu meistern
ihre aktuelle politik dort lediglich
dafür dass deutsche bürger zunehmend
verarmen und unternehmen ins ausland
abwandern und arbeitsplätze bei uns
vernichtet werden die bundesregierung
mit ihrer glorreichen inflationspolitik
hat es in einem halben jahr im amt
geschafft dass wir bei einer
inflationsrate im märz von mittlerweile
über sieben prozent stehen solche
steigerungsraten bei gleichzeitiger
nullzinspolitik hat keine regierung in
den letzten jahrzehnten zu verantworten
gehabt dadurch sind beispielsweise
verlangt wird die mineralöl- dinger
kosten allein im letzten halben jahr um
600 prozent gestiegen dies führt zu
einer steigerung des getreidepreises und
damit auch zur preiserhöhung bei den
lebensmittelkonzern von bis zu 50% jeder
bürger hier im land tragen muss und
jetzt liebe grüne wollen sie den bauern
noch bis zu sieben prozent ihrer
ackerflächen stilllegen diese maßnahme
mit 1300 euro je hektar an steuergeldern
vergüten zusammengefasst ist an diesen
tagen dass die bundesregierung den
landwirten ein produktionsverbot erteilt
was der deutsche bürger mit steuern
bezahlt und als belohnung darf er noch
erheblich teurere lebensmittel bezahlen
wir fordern daher die fachliche
unkenntnis zu beenden und den deutschen
landwirten das freie produzieren von
nahrungs und futtermitteln auf den
angedachten stilllegungs und
ökologischen vorrangflächen zu
ermöglichen mit dieser maßnahme wird
nicht nur die nahrungsmittelpreise in
den deutschen supermärkten wie das
hinten sondern wir könnten allein durch
diese intensive nutzung der angedachten
7% stilllegungsflächen in europa den
getreide import von fast ganz
nordamerika von nordafrika abdecken die
gegen kommission ist unseren forderungen
bereits gefolgt nun haben auch die
vernunft der minister und fördert die
produktion heimischer nahrungs und
futtermitteln und eben nicht den hunger
in der welt stimmen sie unseren bei
gestellten antrag zu vielen dank
während schatten aus und für die fw
fraktion er ist mitglied im ausschuss
für ernährung und landwirtschaft die
nächste rednerin wird der blick
mutmaßlich etwas weiter ziehen über
deutschland hinaus den deborah döring
die jetzt gleich bereiches kommt aus der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und sie
ist entwicklungspolitische sprecherin
ihrer fraktion muss also das große ganze
und globale im blick behalten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen weltweit
hungern zurzeit über 800 millionen
menschen das entspricht der bevölkerung
der eu und nordamerika zusammen aber wer
sich jetzt hier hinstellt und einfach
nur mehr weizenproduktion gepaart mit
weniger klimaschutz fordert der hat das
problem in gänze nicht verstanden
440 millionen menschen stehen kurz vor
dem hungertod und die zahl steigt rasant
an deswegen brauchen wir jetzt eine
massive aufstockung des chronisch
unterfinanzierten
welternährungsprogramms wir müssen den
akuten hunger bekämpfen ja aber das
allein reicht nicht aus wir haben
aktuell genug lebensmittel in der welt
sie sind einfach nur ungerecht verteilt
und das ist auch an sich keine neue
erkenntnis aber wenn ich mir die anträge
und die redebeiträge hier so anhöre dann
scheint es wohl noch nicht bei allen
hier im plenum angekommen zu sein
unsere freihandelspolitik hat die
abhängigkeit des globalen südens von
nahrungsmittelimporten geschaffen zu den
aktuellen krisen haben wir in der eu und
mit unserem weltwirtschaftssystem
beigetragen diese politik hat
lokale ernährungssystem systematisch
zerstört kleinbäuerinnen verdrängt und
die übermacht von multinationalen
konzernen begünstigt und liebe union
ihre verweigerungshaltung der letzten 16
jahre die klimakrise konsequenz nicht
anzugehen hat auch dazu geführt dass
tausende von menschen auf der suche nach
wasser und weideland jetzt schon
vertrieben werden klima die
krisenbedingte dürfen und heuschrecken
sagen führen zu massiven ernteausfällen
und werden es auch weiter tun deswegen
müssen wir mehr klimaschutz fordern und
nicht weniger
und in zügen hinzu kommt dann gerade
noch die krone kann die miete zu extrem
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
verwerfungen im globalen süden geführt
hat in den letzten zwei jahren sind die
lebensmittelpreise gerade wegen dieser
polit an die noch weiter rasant in die
höhe gestiegen der krieg gegen die
ukraine hat diese preis problematik noch
einmal verschärft staaten müssen sich
jetzt weiter verschulden damit sie das
brot für ihre bevölkerung
subventionieren damit sie dass sich
überhaupt noch leisten können in einigen
ländern im globalen süden geben familien
mehr über als 60 prozent ihres gesamten
einkommens für nahrungsmittel aus und
genau das meine ich wenn ich sage diese
krisen hängen zusammen sie verstärken
sich gegenseitig und es gibt keine
eindimensionalen lösungen aller union
für diese mehrdimensionalen probleme
wir müssen aufhören mit kurzfristig
gedachten lösungen diese langfristigen
probleme anzugehen klima und
umweltschutz darf nicht gegen
ernährungssouveränität ausgespielt
werden stattdessen müssen wir an die
strukturen ran ansonsten stehen wir doch
bei den nächsten krisen genauso da wie
wir jetzt dastehen wir brauchen den
biologischen umbau der globalen
landwirtschaft wir müssen
nahrungsmittelspekulationen regulieren
und schuldenmoratorium ermöglichen wir
müssen die globalen ernährungssystem
endlich resilient machen das gilt es
jetzt anzugeben
dafür müssen wir vor einigen im globalen
süden die lokale produktion und
vermarktung von lebensmitteln wieder in
gang bringen wir müssen klein waren
kleinbauern im globalen süden wir
brauchen agrar ökologische ansätze die
ausgebaut werden um die abhängigkeit von
pestizid und mineraldünger zu verringern
im globalen norden ja auch hier müssen
wir handeln und wir müssen die
nahrungsmittel verschwendung drastisch
reduzieren und auch wenn das einigen
kind passt ja das bedeutet auch dass wir
werden lernen müssen weniger tierische
produkte zu konsumieren
und da der kollege der ard gestern dann
mal wieder anfingen die
gleichberechtigung in frage zu stellen
auch hier nochmal ganz klar und deutlich
wir müssen die gleichberechtigung der
geschlechter voranbringen denn der
hunger auf der welt kann nur besiegt
werden wenn weiblich gelesene menschen
endlich gleichberechtigt sind weltweit
sichern vor einigen frauen die ernährung
ihrer familie aber sie werden nicht
gehört sie werden unsichtbar gemacht
bäuerinnen sind der motor für
ernährungssouveränität und ihre
potenziale und fähigkeiten brauchen wir
um den hunger der welt zu überwinden und
das werden wir angehen
hat ihr alle strukturen zu stützen
müssen wir die rechten von frauen
stärken ich komme gar nicht unter die
haben wir jetzt so stadt zeugen
einzuräumen müssen wir länder endlich
ermöglichen soziale sicher unsere firma
aufzubauen wir müssen menschenrechte vor
profit stellen wir müssen
menschenwürdige arbeitsbedingungen
schaffen wir brauchen eine agrar
ökologische transformation mit fairen
und gerechten handel
ernährungssouveränität und
verteilungsgerechtigkeit werden wir
angehen das sind langfristige lösungen
liebe union
die bewegung für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen und sie haben gesehen es
gibt unterschiedliche arten und weisen
auf beiträge zu reagieren hier haben sie
eine ganz spezielle zum schluss noch
einmal gehabt christoph hoffmann ist der
nächste redner stellvertretender
vorsitzender eben ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung und er ist mitglied der
fdp-fraktion im bundestag
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
putin tötet
putin tötet und zerstört
putin tötet in der ukraine aber auch in
den entwicklungs und schwellenländern
der un-generalsekretär antonio guterres
sieht ein wirbelsturm des hungers kommen
in kenia uganda somalia überall
explodieren die lebensmittelpreise und
im südlichen afrika beispielsweise in
malawi ist der brotpreis um 50 prozent
gestiegen das ist ein bisschen mehr wie
beim revier für sie und da sind die
leute die sich das brot kaufen müssen
sie haben sowieso kein geld um sicht
überhaupt nahrungsmittel zu leisten das
ist der unterschied und das haben sich
immer noch nicht verstanden dass die
blogger von der afg
in subsahara afrika sind 144 millionen
menschen auf lebensmittelhilfe der
vereinten nationen angewiesen und das
könnte in den nächsten monaten 30 bis 50
millionen mehr werden und das
welternährungsprogramm muss jetzt mehr
bezahlen für das getreide dass es
sowieso kauft rund 30 prozent mehr der
finanzbedarf der ernährungssicherung
verdoppelt sich
alleiniger grund für den absehbaren
sturm des hungers ist der angriff kriegs
putins auf die besten böden der welt die
ukrainischen schwarzerden ein angriff
auf die kornkammer der welt und die
zerstörung der dazu dienen infrastruktur
wie soll denn vorhandener weizen
überhaupt noch verschifft werden wenn
die häfen zerbombt und vermied sind
darauf geben sie in ihrem antrag liebe
cdu csu auch keine antwort und ich freue
mich auf den austausch in den
ausschüssen dann um über dieses thema
auch zu diskutieren
die humanitäre katastrophe
zeigt putin seine ganze
menschenverachtung mit seinem russischen
exportstopp für weizen gerste mais und
trocken weder uns europäer bestrafen
niemand anderes wie uns nein kaputt hin
nicht mit uns
bedeutet die stabilisierung unruhen
kollaps von staaten ja das nennt putin
bewusst in kauf er will eine neue große
flüchtlingsbewegung starten sie soll dem
erzfeind die humanitär agierende eu an
den rand der möglichkeiten bringen und
dort für unruhe und spaltung sorgen das
ist diese menschen für echte strategie
von herrn putin nein herr putin nicht
mit uns
und dem hunger sterben die ärmsten der
armen die schon vor dem krieg mehr als
die hälfte ihres einkommens ausgegeben
haben für essen nein herr putin nicht
mit uns was sind unsere waffen im krieg
gegen den hunger
kurzfristig und jetzt muss europa und
deutschland bedingungslos seine
nahrungsmittelproduktion steigern da
führt kein weg dran vorbei und das nicht
zu tun wäre eine zynische tödliche
überhebliche arroganz hier haben wir
geostrategische verantwortung
zweitens die zusätzliche finanzielle
hilfe für der bundesregierung für das
welternährungsprogramm hat die
bundesregierung bereits auf den weg
gebracht mit 42 millionen extra hier
agiert die regierung völlig richtig und
das unterstützen wir von den freien
demokraten
mit der entwicklungszusammenarbeit wird
die koalition dafür sorgen dass die
eigenversorgung der länder verbessert
wird ertragreichere pflanzen eine
effizientere landwirtschaft und was
kurzfristig machbar ist sind bessere
lagerungsmöglichkeiten also hier können
wir auch ganz kurzfristig noch helfen
dass wir die lagerungsmöglichkeiten in
diesen ländern verändert verweisung
das sind unsere mittel gegen putins
morden
putins krieg gegen die ukraine ist ein
angriff auf die internationale
weltgemeinschaft
aber wir wir sind bei den mutigen
menschen die in der ukraine auch europas
freiheit und die der welt verteidigen
und bei all jenen freiwilligen und
hauptamtlichen die die reine aller welt
sich gegen diesen hunger hunger stimmen
ging es zum schloss dankern
[Applaus]
und das wort erhält der kollege arthur
auerhammer für die cdu csu fraktion
werde frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
berichten zufolge ist in der ukraine
noch eine fläche von 20 millionen hektar
nicht bestellt es fehlt an diesel fehlt
an dünger es fehlt an saatgut noch viel
schlimmer wir sehen die menschen die den
traktor fahren als in brand zu setzen
und ich bin etwas verwundert dass man
diese debatte zu unseren antrag dann
auch dazu nutzt um alle themen jetzt
wieder aufzumachen und sich nicht
konzentriert auf die bewältigung dieser
humanitären katastrophe die auf uns
zukommt meine
kleine serien
ich bin immer mehr verwundert über das
verhalten der fdp sie machen ja
teilweise kluge vorschläge aber sie
wissen schon dass ihr in einer
ampelkoalition zeit und ihr solltet euch
mal über die osterfeiertage mit der
koalition eine eheberatung suchen oder
irgendwas damit es besser funktionieren
weil was wir in diesem land und was sie
und kleinen nicht gebrauchen kann ist
eine bundesregierung nicht handelt wir
müssen jetzt anderen und es geht darum
dass wir das sie unsere ökologischen
vorrangflächen das sind in
deutschland weit 170 tausend hektar und
ich gebe ihnen auch recht teilweise also
nicht der fdp sondern die grünen dass
nicht jeder quadratmeter hier effektiv
zu nutzen ist weil es grenzvertrag
standortes die habe ich selber ja aber
wenn die von 170000 hängt 100.000 nur
nutzen kann auf 100000 hektar
lebensmittel produzieren kann dann habe
ich auch einen beitrag dazu geleistet
die welternährung zu sichern und wenn zu
1 hektar ist und nicht nur wie sie sagen
man braucht hier mehrere andere ansätze
und ich weise sie eine zwischenfrage
wenn die frau künast mir glaubhaft
versichert sie hat eine nette frau
gegangen
also ich nehme das als ein jahr bevor
sich
die nette frage ist möchten sie sich
nicht in einem redebeitrag auf etwas
anderes konzentrieren weil ich nämlich
gehört habe dass jetzt im bundesrat der
vorschlag von cem özdemir gerade
durchgegangen ist also der aufwuchs auf
den flächen und bestimmter anderer kann
stattfinden dann ist doch so weit erst
mal gut rechtlich zeitlich ist es
ähnlich veränderbar also lassen wir uns
über die zukunft reden und die bauern
werden diesen einen teil gerne nutzen
liebe frau kühles ich bin dankbar für
diese frage weil sie dazu mir mehr
redezeit geben ja wenn sie die beratung
im bundesrat verfolgt haben dann gab es
einen antrag der auf diesen flächen auch
landwirtschaftlichen nutzung zulassen
sollte mit den einsatz von
pflanzenschutzmittel mit den einsatz von
düngemitteln
diese ist abgelehnt worden und jetzt ist
nur
genehmigt worden dass man die futter
nutzung von diesen flächen nutzen kann
jetzt frage ich sie liebe frau künast
ich komme aus der landwirtschaft ich
kenne die selbst richte die da drauf
stehen auf diesen flächen also ich weiß
nicht ob so manche kuh begeistert ist
wenn man sie mit display fördert also es
ist kein beitrag zur welternährung was
sie hier leisten mit diesen beschluss
nicht wir brauchen eine
aktivierung dieser landwirtschaftlichen
nutzflächen sie sich widersetzen
dankeschön
mai verwehren
es ist ja auch so dass uns die zeit
davon läuft am 23 märz hat die eu
kommission hat brüssel bereits
beschlossen wir können diese flecken
nutzen vom 23 schmerz bis letztes
wochenende waren die besten
aussaatbedingungen in deutschland unsere
bäuerinnen unsere bauern hätten sehen
können sie hätten harfe für ihre familie
frau künast auch serien können ja das
konnten sie nicht was sie es verhindert
haben mit jeder bundesregierung
und
auch die eu hat vorgegeben es muss
innerhalb von 21 tagen entschieden
werden und der entschluss der jetzt im
bundesrat parallel gefasst es ist ein
minimalkompromiss
dem wir
mittragen aber es wesen werden
wesentlich mehr drin gewesen
und wenn wir dann über die weitere
ausführung der agrarpolitik in den
nächsten jahren reden dann ist ja auch
klar die forderung dass diese
vierprozentige stilllegung ab 2023 in
der gap mal hinterfragt werden soll
dann lasst uns doch darüber diskutieren
dass wir jetzt diese vier prozent
schädigung nicht machen dass wir
nächstes jahr auch hier lebensmittel
produzieren und was ihn zwei drei vier
fünf jahren ist da müssen wir dann
wieder neu darüber diskutieren wir
hatten in europa schon war eine
stilllegung von 10 prozent können sich
vielleicht nicht ganz jüngeren noch
daran erinnern damals war die
stilllegung deswegen so hoch weil eine
überproduktion in europa stattgefunden
haben und jetzt müssen wir haben wir als
deutsche auch die verantwortung
lebensmittel zu produzieren für die
länder die es nicht mehr haben für die
länder die vom klimawandel betroffen
sind wir haben eine humanitäre
verantwortung hier als deutsche
bundestag auch meine damen und herren
und ich will ihnen das noch mal sagen
ich finde sie ein coup wenn wir gewisse
ökologische maßnahme machen aber eins
stellen wir zurzeit auch fest auf den
ideologischen grünen spielwiesen da
wächst kein produkt getreide das muss
uns klar sein und die menschen brauchen
jetzt ernährung die menschen brauchen
jetzt was zum essen wasser bringt vielen
dank artur auernhammer das aus der csu
landwirtschaftsmeister und staatlich
geprüfter landwirt und wir kommen in die
schlussphase dieser debatte mit
franziska kersten die drittletzte
rednerin ist kommt aus der spd-fraktion
und ist mitglied im parlamentarischen
beirat für nachhaltige entwicklung und
das ist ganz interessant im parlament
hat dieser beirat eine sogenannte
wachhund funktion das heißt er im bild
in anführungszeichen natürlich nur
sobald ein vorhaben die nationale
nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
außer acht lässt außer acht lässt mit
anhörungen und positionspapieren wurden
debatten beispielsweise angestoßen zu
und aus seiner sicht nötigen punkten und
jetzt die abgeordnete beteiligt sind der
krieg führt zu großem leid bei den
betroffenen ländern aber er kann auch zu
einer hungerkrise in der welt führen
zusammen mit den dürren mittelamerikas
afrikas und dem nahen osten kann eine
ernährungskrise entstehen die zu neuen
fluchtbewegungen führen kann was können
wir und was müssen wir tun zuerst geht
es um die hilfen für die geflüchteten
und die menschen in der ukraine
und da helfen wir selbstverständlich
jetzt schon auch die agrarpolitik muss
reagieren richtig ist dass deutschland
ein landwirtschaftlicher kunststandort
ist richtig ist aber auch dass wir mit
wetterkapriolen leben müssen hagel
starkregen und dass da mehr oder weniger
durchaus unsere erträge auch gefährdet
sind dagegen wurde unsere landwirtschaft
nur dann gewappnet sein wenn wir
resilient agrarische ökosysteme schaffen
das bedeutet regionalen er
stoffkreisläufe mit futter erzeugung und
dünger verwertung vor ort zu schaffen
und breitere acht folgen zu fördern wir
müssen die biodiversität als absoluten
entscheidenden faktor der
widerstandsfähigkeit unsere agrar
systeme erhöhen das erfordern die
exzellenten agrarwissenschaftler des
landes schon länger daher kann auch die
konsequenz aus der aktuellen krise nicht
sein passieren um jeden preis und wir
haben die ganzen zahlen gehört 170
hektar und was man da erzeugen kann und
so weiter wir können damit nicht
tatsächlich den welthunger so bewerten
als dass es uns eine langfristige
perspektive gibt wir müssen weg und und
damit importen aus übersee und zu einer
flächen gebotenen tierhaltung kommen wir
können vielleicht eine zeitlich
befristete abstufung von tierbeständen
auch dazu führen dass er weniger
futtergetreide brauchen und dort mehr
für die ernährung anzubauen vielleicht
als tierärztin und rinder züchterin fand
ich sagen wenn sie jetzt die vier
millionen milchkühe deutschlands mal
einfach die reaktion im kraft- oder um
ein kilo kraftfutter reduzieren dann
würden sie ungefähr die getreidemenge
sparen die auf den ökologischen
vorrangflächen bei absolute ausnutzung
der fläche erwirtschaftet werden könnte
mama darüber nachdenken ist vielleicht
eine variante gut währung
ihre anstrengungen die reform der
europäischen agrarpolitik hin schreiben
hat der silly enten ein kilo kraftfutter
ist kein tierschutz keine kursdebatte
gar nicht gerne noch mal ein bisschen
nachlesen eine rasierte land und
ernährungswirtschaft anzuhalten oder
umzudrehen ist praktisch zum scheitern
verurteilt unbestritten ist die
verknappung von futtermitteln übrigens
im ökologischen bereich noch stärker als
im konventionellen bereich und darauf
wurde er jetzt auch im bundesrat die
entscheidung praktisch durchgesetzt dass
diese aufwuchs für futtermittel genutzt
werden kann wir sind hoffentlich nicht
nur disteln sie tun so als wären es die
besten flächen der land wurde ich glaube
jeder wirtschaften gelangt wird weiß
dass er da grenzt ertrags standorten
nimmt und sie müssen nur mit
pflanzenschutzmittel und düngemitteln
die so auf button die sind aber teuer
wie wollen sie das finanziell ausrechnen
wenn sie praktisch da noch mehr aufbauen
und dann erinnere ich an das laufende
vertragsverletzungsverfahren vertrag ich
glaube dass die erhöhte düngung dieser
grenze standorte nicht dazu beiträgt
dass wir unsere nitrat richtlinie
einhalten und das wird möglicherweise er
die zahlung die zwangs zahlungen noch
eher befürchten müssen
sie müssen also schon das ist ein gelber
politik ist übrigens stellt sich auch
die frage warum wir bei uns 80 prozent
bankfähigen weizen produzieren und dich
den eigentlich 30 30 prozent von dem wir
eigentlich nur die bäckereien brauchen
wir können also futterweizen herstellen
auf diesen flächen ohne vermehrt dünger
aufzubringen und sie haben dann auch
noch höhere erträge also ist auch eine
variante die sicherlich gut ins bild
passen würde
doch auf den flächen wo sie jetzt weizen
anbauen dürfen sie auch mit weniger
dingen einfach futterweizen anbauen und
nicht um war alles nur auf diese
absoluten proteingehalt man muss a und c
walzen mit einer proteingehalt von 11
prozent hat höhere back fähigkeit als
weizen mit zwölf oder 13 prozent
es will noch besonders wichtig studien
haben ergeben dass fast die hälfte der
obst- und gemüseproduktion der tonne
landet hier müssen wir ansetzen und hier
kann jeder einzelne schon heute mittag
seinen beitrag leisten um eine
nachhaltige klimaschonende
landwirtschaft und eine
ernährungssicherheit in einklang zu
bringen vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die cdu csu fraktion erhält jetzt
das wort der kollege dr wolfgang steht
finger
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir nehmen es den hungernden um die
färbungen denn vor dem tod zu bewahren
diese aussage von verantwortlichen des
world food programms aus den letzten
tagen verdeutlicht in welcher
dramatischen situationen viele länder
vor allem auch entwicklungsländer sind
und diese aussage führt uns außerdem vor
dass dieser brutale angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine nicht nur unermessliches
leid für die bürger in der ukraine mit
sich bringt sondern auch in zahlreichen
entwicklungsländern den hunger
zurückbringt länder meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren die ohnehin oftmals zu
den ärmsten ländern der welt gehören in
denen mangelernährung auch zu normalen
zeiten keine seltenheit ist und auch in
länder deren finanzielle möglichkeiten
begrenzt sind schon auch aufgrund der
korona pandemie und jetzt heute kaum
noch vorhanden sind im libanon
ist in seit ungefähr einer woche das
brot rationiert die preise sind um 20
prozent gestiegen 66 prozent des weizens
kamen bisher aus der ukraine in somalia
sind die preise für weiz um 300 prozent
gestiegen tunesien libyen gambia
mauretanien eritrea ägypten cetera die
liste der länder die von hunger und
armut oder auch von steigenden preis und
betroffen sind ließe sich also beliebig
fortsetzen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die ukraine wird aufgrund des
krieges größtenteils als weizen
lieferant in diesem jahr ausfallen und
die bilder aus den kriegsgebieten haben
wir alle vor augen aber auch die bilder
der hungernden menschen der hungernden
kinder und deswegen sage ich ganz
deutlich krieg ist mord und wo mit gerd
müller es zusagen auch hunger ist mord
und
dieser hunger führt zwangsläufig zu
zunehmenden konflikten konflikte
bedeuten instabilität aufstände
gewalttätige auseinandersetzungen sind
die folge und ich darf im zusammenhang
auf der heutigen debatte an die getreide
preissteigerungen vor rund zehn jahren
erinnern und zu welchen folgen diese
geführt haben viele dieser folgen
beschäftigen uns ja auch noch heute und
deswegen ist es ehrlicherweise unredlich
frau thüringen sie hier so diesen
moralischen zeigefinger
bringen und jetzt versuchen die klima
den klimawandel hieraus zu spielen sie
fliegen ja soweit ich weiß am
ostermontag nach mali vielleicht fragen
sie dort mal die mütter mit den
hungernden kindern was sie davon halten
dass ihnen der klimawandel gerade
wichtiger ist als die ernährung der
kinder und
ich sage ihnen ganz deutlich
ich sage ihnen ganz deutlich deutschland
und deutschland und europa müssen jetzt
handeln sonst sie dafür dass die
potenziale ausgeschöpft werden können in
der landwirtschaft sorgen sie dafür dass
wir möglichst schnell auch den ländern
im globalen süden helfen können wir
müssen landwirtschaft wir müssen
ernährung und entwicklung zusammen
denken es braucht eine langfristige
strategie liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
auch vor dem hintergrund des
klimawandels deswegen braucht es neben
dem vernetzten ansatz sicherheit und
entwicklung auch eine vernetzung von
agrarpolitik und entwicklungspolitik und
was ich überhaupt nicht verstehen können
dass sie haben das world food programm
auch angesprochen dass ihre regierung im
aktuellen haushalt des
entwicklungsministeriums das world food
programm um 50 prozent kürzen dass ihre
regierung die sonder initiative eine
welt ohne hunger um 60 millionen kürzt
die aktuelle situation gebietet etwas
anderes und sie stellen sich hierhin
moralisch mit ihrem zeigefinger und
versuchen hier die großen reden zu
halten
ich sage ihnen eines co-präsidentin ich
sage ihnen eines natürlich kann man vom
geld nicht runterreißen aber es braucht
eben auch die potenziale in der
landwirtschaft und die müssen wir jetzt
heben und zwar schnell geben natürlich
auch in diesen ländern aber es muss
jetzt schnell gehen es muss jetzt
schnell gehen fragen hast und deswegen
müssen wir hier zügig handeln sie müssen
handeln sie sind in der regierung es
reicht nicht immer nur zu warnen ihre
minister war sie bitten handeln sie
wo es kein steht genau war das und ihn
wird jetzt folgen die letzte rednerin in
dieser debatte derya thurk nach bauer
nochmal spd fraktion
und als letzte rednerin in dieser
debatte erhält das wort die kollegin der
türk nachbauer
der frau präsidentin meine damen und
herren viele punkte wurden heute schon
angesprochen
ich gehe jetzt den oder ich möchte im
fokus auf die themen welternährung und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit leben für uns
steht fest wir werden die menschen in
der ukraine nicht im stich lassen nicht
heute und nicht morgen
wäre wäre alles dafür tun dass die
ernährungssituation nicht nur vor ort
sondern auch welt mal stabil bleibt
zumindest vorerst stabil bleibt und wir
wollen sie auch verbessern aber nicht
nur wir als politikerinnen und politiker
im parlament und der regierung helfen
wie und wo wir können ich möchte an
dieser stelle auf meinen dank an die
vielen privatwirtschaftlichen
unternehmen aussprechen die bereits seit
wochen ihre fahrzeuge für den transport
von lebensmitteln und anderen
hilfsgütern in die kriegs gebeutelte
ukraine bereitstellen danke dafür
im landwirtschaftsministerium wird
ebenso mit hochdruck in der koordination
verteilung und des transports von
lebensmittel gearbeitet und es
funktioniert vielen dank dafür herr
bundesminister und das liebe bmv kofler
vielen dank wir konnten uns nämlich
selber ein bild davon machen hatte vor
einigen tagen in der grenzregion der
ukraine war
diese sehen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der union der antrag kommt in
einigen punkten etwas verspätet auch
ohne ihr einige gut gemeinten hinweise
hat ja wir kommen zurück im bundesrat
letzten zwei drei minuten in der debatte
über eine nahrungsmittelversorgung
weltweit aber auch in der ukraine am
pult ist der türke nachbauer für die
spd-fraktion 30 millionen euro
angekündigt allerdings ist das noch am
anfang ich möchte explizit betont dass
auch die übrigen geberländer im rahmen
der g7 aufgefordert sind ebenfalls noch
erhebliche finanzielle mittel zur
verfügung zu stellen noch einmal die
ausreichende finanzierung des
welternährungsprogramms liegt
insbesondere am herzen dieses programm
ist dann unabdingbares instrument zur
weltweiten bekämpfung von hunger und
mangelernährung
ich möchte nicht wieder die bilder und
die folgen der unterfinanzierung erleben
wie wir sie damals in syrien krieg
erlebt haben diese finanzierung
erfordert keine hochtrabenden titel oder
wohlklingenden namen wie sieht manchmal
aus dem bmz früher gehört haben denn es
kommt allein auf den inhalt und die
wirksamkeit der finanzierung an diese
hilfe muss unbürokratisch und in mit
unmittelbar bei denen ankommen die sie
ganz dringend brauchen
so
fällt die umsetzung findet bereits seit
langem an intensiver austausch zwischen
den beteiligten ministerien stadt dafür
mussten keine sonderposten oder ganz
neue titel geschaffen werden vielmehr
waren sich alle beteiligten in dieser
regierung einig dass eine schnelle
unterstützung priorität hat ferner
planen wir neben bestehenden programm
der bilateralen zusammenarbeit weitere
maßnahmen diese werden auf lange sicht
die landwirtschaftliche produktion in
unseren partnern land sichern und sie
unabhängig von russischen derzeit
exporten machen ich glaube daran dass
eine welt ohne hunger möglich ist wenn
der politische wille da ist eine welt
ohne hunger ist auch der name ans
ernährungsprogramms und wird eines tages
hoffentlich realität werden auch trotz
der kriegs treibenden aggression
demokratiefeindliche diktaturen am ende
möchte ich von erwähnten zu dem
überleiten dass jeder einzelne von uns
jetzt tun kann um jetzt weltweit den
hungernden menschen wenigstens minimal
zu helfen ohne viel aufwand ohne viel
aufhebens ich möchte an uns alle
appellieren
lassen sie uns unsere eigenen
gewohnheiten bei der ernährung unter die
lupe nehmen das ist uns gemeinsam auch
im kleinen etwas verändern reduzieren
heißt nicht unbedingt verzichten
wir werden diese etwas aus der zeit
gefallenen antrag nicht zustimmen danke
der türke war die letzte rednerin in
einer debatte des bundestages zum thema
ukraine hilfe zur
nahrungsmittelversorgung weltweit aber
auch zur lage der ernährungslage in der
ukraine jetzt